Hello, everyone, and welcome
to our live prime-time special
"A Closer Look Thursday."
Now, normally,
on our show every night,
we do a segment called
"A Closer Look"
that's about 15 minutes long.
But, since so much
has happened this week,
we decided to supersize it
from 15 minutes
to 21 minutes.
It might not sound like a lot,
but those extra
six minutes, man,
they're gonna blow your mind.
Also, this will be
the first time
we're doing "A Closer Look"
with commercial breaks
and I, for one,
can't wait to see
which ads for prescription drugs
NBC thinks pair best
with a rundown of today's news.
Xanex, Dramamine, Regeneron?
Sorry, just trying
to help the president
pump up the stock price.
And, speaking
of the president --
That's a segue.
We're incredibly good at those.
There's so much to get to,
from the president's ongoing
election-induced meltdown
to the White House attempt
to cover up
its expanding COVID outbreak.
So, for more on all of that,
it's time for "A Closer Look"
prime time!
♪♪
I forgot --
NBC wouldn't pay
for the second camera.
This week, our addled president
has been sitting around
in a mostly deserted
White House infectious zone,
watching TV
and angrily scream-tweeting
at all hours of the night.
The place is turning
into Grey Gardens.
If Trump gets reelected,
he's gonna be holed up in there
with long hair and fingernails,
while flies buzz
around Mike Pence's head.
Trump's apparently just been
watching TV and stewing
as the White House
COVID outbreak
spirals further out of control
and his poll numbers continue
to tank, with less than
four weeks until the election.
And, plus, he's been
on a combination
of powerful steroids
and experimental drugs,
while frying his brain
with hours of cable news.
So, exactly what you want
from the guy
in charge
of the nuclear arsenal.
They're gonna have to keep
that briefcase away from him
the way you hide
a tennis ball from a dog.
For example, today he called in
for yet another one
of his televised
therapy sessions
with Fox Business host
Maria Bartiromo,
where he, once again,
rambled incoherently about,
honestly, God knows what.
It's impossible to follow,
unless you're deeply immersed
in the Fox News
cinematic universe
of gripes
and conspiracy theories.
Basically, it was just
two crazy people
yelling over the phone
like divorced parents
Facetiming each other
on Thanksgiving.
-I'm not gonna waste my time
on a virtual debate.
That's not what debating's
all about.
You sit behind a computer
and do a debate.
It's ridiculous.
For six months,
he was fracking.
He was raising his very thin
hand and he was fracking.
I don't think
I'm contagious, at all.
It's particles of dust.
It's tiny stuff.
I'm back because I'm
a perfect physical specimen.
They want to hug me and they
want to kiss me, and they do.
These people should be indicted.
This was the greatest
political crime
in the history of our country,
and that includes Obama
and it includes Biden.
Mailmen are being,
as you know, indicted.
One was indicted yesterday
in New Jersey.
-Wow.
-They found traces of ballots
in a river.
I killed Soleimani.
I killed al-Baghdadi.
Names that everybody --
bigger names
than Osama bin Laden.
She's a Communist.
They have a boat,
saying they have 5,000 boats.
They have thousands of trucks
all over the country.
I'm essentially very clean.
-Oh, settle down, my man.
Can we cut his steroids
with some of that Xanax
or maybe, I don't know,
a full Thanksgiving turkey?
Listening to one of these
interviews with Trump
is like taking a bunch of your
racist uncle's Facebook posts
and putting them in a blender.
He's talking about boats,
indited mailmen,
rivers full of ballots,
calling himself
a "perfect physical specimen,"
all of which are lies,
obviously.
He sounds like he's
writing a YA novel
after burying his face
in a mound of Adderall.
[ As Trump ]
The rivers are full of ballots.
Mailmen have been indicted.
Tiny dust particles
are everywhere!
Everyone is contagious,
except for me, your hero,
the perfect physical specimen.
Krr!
Hrrrr!
Aaah!
Even Bartiromo, one of Trump's
most obsequious sycophants,
who spends most of the interview
goading him on,
tried to get him
off the phone at one point
and, as she was wrapping up,
he screamed something incoherent
about indicting Hillary Clinton.
-Well, I'd like to go back
to the White House soon
to do another interview,
Mr. President.
-Oh, we'll do that, Maria.
-I'd like to come back
to the White House.
-I saw it up close
-Well, why isn't Hillary Clinton
-and personal.
-being indicted?
-That's just how
he says goodbye now.
"Bye, Donald! Have a good why
isn't Hillary being indicted."
[ As Trump ]
And a good why isn't Hillary
being indicted to you.
Trump has concocted
an elaborate fantasy
in which his political opponents
committed treason against him
and has called
for his predecessor,
his previous opponent,
and his current opponent
to all be prosecuted and jailed.
This is how erratic and unstable
our political system has been
under Trump and the GOP.
In fact,
today the president released
yet another one of his
bizarre Twitter videos,
where he stands
outside the White House
and rambles in a way
that would make you think
the drugs are kicking in,
except, you know,
he's Donald Trump.
Here he is addressing seniors.
-You're not vulnerable, but they
like to say the vulnerable,
but you're the least vulnerable.
But for this one thing,
you are vulnerable.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, thanks
for clearing it up.
So -- I'm sorry.
Are they vulnerable or not?
[ As Trump ]
They say you're vulnerable,
but you're not.
But, for this, you are.
Even though, in general,
you're not.
You're invulnerable
to being vulnerable,
which means
you're not vulnerable,
unless you're vulnerable.
It's like an ancient riddle
scrawled on an Egyptian cave.
If you're a senior watching that
and you want to know
if you're vulnerable now,
you need a decoder ring.
Also, why is he so far away?
You know, you're contagious
when they make you stand
multiple football fields
away from the White House.
Did the White House get
a restraining order against him?
[ As Trump ]
Judge says I need to stay
at least 200 feet away.
So the Trump White House
is a pandemic hot zone,
staffers and journalists
are either quarantined
or working from home,
and the ones who are there
have to wear gowns, masks,
and eye covers.
Right now, the White House
is more deserted
than a CVS at midnight.
"Hello!
Hello, does anybody work here?
Sir, do you work here?"
[ As Pence ]
I do work here and I --
and I want to thank you
for the opportunity
to answer that question.
"You know, I'm just looking
for some toilet paper."
I keep in my heart
every customer
who's looking for toilet paper.
"So it would be where?"
Soleimani is responsible
for the deaths of --
"Oh, that's -- no, that's not
an answer to my question.
So you're just gonna --
you're just gonna answer
the question
you want to answer?"
Seriously, by the time
Trump's term ends,
the West Wing's gonna be like
one of those spooky
abandoned houses
at the end of your cul-de-sac
your parents tell you
to stay away from.
Kids are gonna dare
each other to go inside
and, occasionally,
we'll see Steven Miller walk
out into the backyard
with a garbage bag and a shovel.
In fact -- this is real --
the White House is so abandoned,
it's been infested
with raccoons.
A CNN reporter was even
captured fighting one off
right before a live shot.
-Where?
Get!
There he is.
[ Thud ]
Aaaah!
[ Laughter ]
-That do it?
-Now, no events
on the president's
schedule today.
-[ Laughing ]
Good Lord.
The White House has turned
into a video game level
from "Resident Evil."
"I just got to kill
five radioactive raccoons
and then I get another
health pack."
Every day, it seems,
the number of people connected
to the White House cluster
who test positive
for coronavirus grows
and, now, even the agency
in charge
of federal disaster response
is getting involved.
-This morning,
the coronavirus outbreak
on the grounds
of the White House
even worse than the Trump
administration has admitted.
ABC News obtained
an internal memo
sent Wednesday
to top officials at FEMA,
listing the total number
of infected White House staffers
and other contacts at 34.
That's 10 more than had been
previously known.
-That's right, FEMA -- FEMA --
is writing memos
about the White House now.
I know there's a lot about the
Trump era that's on the nose,
but even I never imagined
the White House
would become
a literal disaster zone.
Soon, we're gonna see
Trump sleeping on a cot
in a high school gymnasium.
He's gonna film his next
"Everything is going great"
video
wrapped in a tinfoil blanket,
eating beans from a can
with a plastic spoon.
[ As Trump ]
We beat it, folks.
Corona's on the run and I think
we can all agree that is
cool beans.
And think
about how crazy that is.
At least 34 people
have now been infected
with the coronavirus
and it's not just the staffers
inside the White House
or Trump's inner circle.
A shocking report published
yesterday by USA Today
found that the White House
coronavirus outbreak
may have exposed
thousands of people
across multiple states.
He's Typhoid Mary,
if she held rallies.
Of course, it seems like this
can all be traced back
to what appears to have been
a superspreader event
at the White House last month
to introduce Trump's nominee
for the Supreme Court,
Amy Coney Barrett.
And this whole episode has been
a perfect encapsulation
of the criminal negligence,
ineptitude, secrecy,
and recklessness
with which
the Trump administration
has handled the pandemic,
as a whole.
For one thing,
people were hugging
and talking in close
proximity to each other,
and they even held indoor events
without masks
or social distancing.
It's not just your own health.
You're putting others
at risk.
Engaging in this kind
of behavior during a pandemic
is like slathering
in yourself in honey
and whacking a hornet's nest
with a baseball bat,
which I guess would explain
why Trump's face
always looks like he just
pulled it out of a beehive.
[ As Trump ]
What can I say?
Daddy's got a sweet tooth.
And, by the way,
the only reason they rushed
to hold this superspreader
gala, in the first place,
was so they could pack the court
with a 6-3 supermajority
before an election.
Trump is actively trying
to undermine
and to rule on a case
in November
in which
the Trump administration
is suing to destroy Obamacare
and rip healthcare
away from 20 million,
including those
with preexisting conditions
and, in doing so, they ended up
getting themselves sick.
The irony is almost
Shakespearean.
All this thing needed was
Trump delivering a monologue
to a skull.
[ As Trump ]
Alas, poor Yorick!
His doctor was out-of-network.
But as bad as the
outbreak itself was,
the attempt to cover it up
was egregious.
We'll tell you all about that
when we come back.
-[ Snarling ]
-Oh!
The raccoons are here.
I thought we sprayed.
Oh, they're drawn to his voice?
Okay, well, that's on us, then.
Alright.
We'll be right back
after I take care of this.
Shoo!
♪♪
Welcome back, everybody.
Now, the White House's
reckless behavior
is especially galling
when we know
there are basic
public health measures
that work and that would help
stop the spread of this disease
and save lives,
as Dr. Anthony Fauci
explained this week.
-It occurs because of the lack
of implementation
of simple
public health measures.
It's so frustrating because
it's not rocket science.
You almost want to say,
"Okay, country, you know,
maybe 50% of you hate me
because you think I'm trying
to destroy the country,
but do me a favor.
Listen to me for like
maybe six weeks or so
and do these things.
You would see the level
of infection go down."
-Okay, first of all,
it's much less than 50%.
Polls show as much
as three-fourths of Americans
regularly wear masks
and support mask mandates.
The people who are opposed
are really only like 20%.
You know, the modern-day
wannabe Minutemen you see
in viral videos, who think
they're standing up for freedom
by screaming
at a teenage employee
in the frozen aisle at Costco.
"Oh, what's next,
you're gonna tell me
I can't run my hands
through the ground beef?"
[ Squeakily ]
Oh, yeah. You should
never do that.
"Well, I guess we're living
in Nazi Russia now!
Kyle!"
Second, you're right.
It's not rocket science,
except to Donald Trump,
because, to him,
everything is rocket science.
Explaining how viral
transmission works to this guy
is like explaining
the mechanics
of the internal
combustion engine
to a capuchin monkey.
He's just gonna get bored
and start picking flies
out of Pence's hair.
[ As Pence ]
How do you think
I did last night, sir?
[ As Trump ]
You were great, Mike.
But, as we've said many times,
it's not just Trump.
He's not unique
among Republicans.
For example, the president's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani
literally showed up maskless
to a crowded indoor fundraiser
in Manhattan this week,
a day after coughing so much
in a Fox News interview
that even the anchor
expressed concern.
And, by the way,
as he was doing this interview,
he was waiting
for his COVID test results.
-Mayor, you heard
Joe Biden there.
He says, if the scientists
-[ Coughs ]
-say it's okay.
-When I hear that response --
[ Coughs ]
-You know, everybody
questions the polls.
-[ Coughs ]
-We'll look forward
to having you back
and I hope that cough
is not anything bad.
You're waiting for your test
to come back,
so, we hope you're gonna
be healthy and well.
-I hope so, too!
-[ As Giuliani ]
I hope so, too!
I don't wanna die!
Again!
There's only so many times
they can Jon Snow you!
How far did they push that swab
up your nose, Rudy?
is it possible they
left it in there?
"Mr. Giuliani,
we do need to remove the swab
to test the sample."
[ As Giuliani ]
Hey, finders keepers, guys.
Free swab for Rudy.
It's insane that someone
who traveled with Trump
just days before his
positive COVID test
feels comfortable showing up
to a TV studio without a mask
and coughing like
a high school sophomore
who just got bullied into
smoking their first cigarette.
Now, it would be great
to know more about the timeline
of the White House
COVID outbreak,
but the administration
has repeatedly lied
about what happened and refused
to provide basic information
about when Trump
last tested negative,
which is important
because the president attended
or traveled to a slew of events
in the days before his
positive diagnosis,
from the first presidential
debate to a rally in Minnesota,
to an indoor fundraiser
in New Jersey,
all without masks
or social distancing.
He's like the
Johnny Appleseed of COVID.
He's a one-man superspreader.
And, no, I'm not talking
about that weird,
superspreading, accordion thing
he does with his hands,
you know,
where he puts his arms out
like he's being
patted down by the TSA.
"Sir, do you know why
we pulled you out of the line?"
[ As Trump ]
Is it because my coat is
loaded up with office supplies
I borrowed from the Oval Office?
"Hey, man, I heard you're
the guy selling staplers."
Not now, buddy.
We need to know when Trump
was potentially infected,
for the sake of all the people
who could've been exposed,
and yet, for some reason,
the White House refuses
to just tell us
when Trump's
last negative test was.
But, as always,
with this White House,
if they're not giving us
an answer,
it's probably because
that answer is damning.
There's almost no chance
Trump has been getting tested.
If Trump tested negative
even once,
he'd be holding up
the test results
the way Henry Winkler holds up
fish on Twitter. For real.
You've got to follow the guy.
It's a good time.
There's a good chance
Trump wasn't tested at all,
which would contradict
all the bragging they did,
just months ago, about how
often they tested Trump
and everyone around him.
-As I've made clear
from this podium,
the president is the most
tested man in America.
-I do take, probably on average,
a test every two days,
three days.
-I'm sorry. Why not every day?
You're the president.
I mean, I get tested
three days a week
and I'm hardly
an essential worker.
The only reason I'm even
on prime time right now is
because they had
to shut down production
on "Superstore"
for a few months.
Come back, "Superstore."
I like my normal time slot,
where I can say the F-word
and they can bleep it in post.
So, now, it turns out
Trump was not
"the most tested man
in America."
Also, it wouldn't surprise me
if Trump just refused
to be tested,
since he's openly complained
about how much he dislikes
the nasal swab test.
-Uh --
Not something I wanna do
every day. I can tell you that.
it's a test.
It's a medical test.
Nothing pleasant about it.
-It's not pleasant for you,
with those nostrils?
I mean, come on.
Those things are like mainsails.
They probably had to tape
two swabs together
to get all the way up there.
"[ Grunt ]
I'm not hitting anything,
but I'm afraid to keep going."
So it's not surprising
Trump would try
to cover up a COVID outbreak,
but even for him,
the last few days have been
especially unhinged,
and we'll tell you all about
the president's latest outburst
when we come right back.
♪♪
Welcome back.
Now, we don't really
know anything
about the president's health,
other than what he tells us
in those weird,
one-take Twitter videos
he keeps posting
from the White House grounds.
You know, the ones
with weird jump cuts
and trucks backing up
in the background.
-Firefighters, everybody,
they're just great.
We have great people.
This is a great country.
I wanted to get
out of the hospital
[ Alert beeping ]
and that's what I want
for everybody.
-Where is he,
a construction site?
He couldn't tape his message
to the country
after garbage collection?
Who knows, though? Maybe the
beeps are coming from him.
It makes sense because,
every time he talks,
he's basically backing up
a truck full of BS.
Also, what is up with the
terrible production quality?
He's the president.
I feel like he's trying
to sell me
a reverse mortgage
or an above-ground pool.
It's not good when the
White House films the president
in the same style
as the "Cloverfield" monster.
Now, we know the coronaviruses
taken a visible toll
on Trump's physical health,
but there's also been
some speculation
about his mental health,
given that the steroids
he's taking
can reportedly have
psychological side effects.
And I'm no mental health expert,
but I can tell the difference
between bad and worse,
although I don't really know
how you'd know.
Taking the drugs
made Trump crazier
is like saying the Nikes
made Usain Bolt faster.
Dude can't get much faster
than he already did.
But don't worry --
Trump put any questions
about his state of mind
to rest with this video.
-Hi.
Perhaps you recognize me.
It's your favorite president
and I'm standing in front of the
Oval Office at the White House,
which is always
an exciting place to be.
-When he says, "Hi. It's me,
your favorite president,"
it almost sounds like
he's being ironic,
like even he knows how much
people don't like him.
Like he's expecting
the Debbie Downer music.
-Hi.
Perhaps you recognize me.
It's your favorite president.
[ Sad trombone plays ]
[ Laughing ]
Thank you, Dratch.
Now, ever since
his positive test,
Trump has been telling people
not to be afraid of COVID
and that we shouldn't let it
dominate our lives,
which, of course,
is easy for him to say,
since he lives in a mansion
with an in-house clinic
and was literally flown
by helicopter
to a premier
medical institution,
where he received the best
taxpayer-funded health care
in the world.
Trump hates universal,
single-payer healthcare,
until he needs it,
then, he turns into a socialist.
He's gonna show up
to his next press conference
in a headband and Karl Marx
T-shirt, shouting --
[ As Trump ]
We must pass Medicare for All
Who Are Named Donald Trump.
In fact, The New York Times
did the math
and estimated that Trump's care
would've cost the average
American $100,000.
And something tells me
you still wouldn't hit
your out-of-pocket limit.
"What's my deductible?
A billion dollars?!
That can't be right.
Let me get my insurance card.
Oh, oh, I apologize.
It is a billion dollars."
And, of course,
it's an especially sweet deal
for Trump, given that,
in 2016 and '17,
he paid only $750 in federal
income taxes per year.
If Trump loses in November,
it would be great
if Biden sent him a bill
for $99,250,
just to watch him sweat.
[ As Trump ] I'll get you
the money, Joe. I swear.
I just need one more hit
of dexamethasone.
Daddy's gotta get his dex on.
Gotta get on that
♪ Highway to ♪
♪ Dexamethasone ♪
[ Laughter ]
So Trump got the best
medical care in the world,
at taxpayer expense,
medical care no other
American has access to,
including an experimental drug
made by a company called
Regeneron.
And, yes, before you even ask,
the CEO is a member
of Trump's golf course
and, yes, Trump has owned
stock in the past
and, yes, they got a giant
$450 million grant
from the Trump
administration in July
because, of course, why else
would Trump go out of his way
to repeatedly brag about it
in his video?
-They gave me Regeneron.
It's called Regeneron.
And other things, too,
but I think this was the key.
[ Alert beeping ]
But they gave me Regeneron
and it was like unbelievable.
I felt good immediately.
I felt as good three days ago
as I do now.
-Okay, first of all,
Regeneron sounds like a drug
an evil corporation
in the movie would use
to make an army of soldiers
or genetically engineer
dinosaurs.
All it's missing is the word
industries at the end.
"Here at Regeneron Industries,
we're using
the latest technology
to create an army
of servant clones
that definitely will not
rise up against --
What's that banging
on the door?
Oh, the servant clones?
Oh, they're rising up?
We'll turn them off.
They won't turn off?
Well, I don't know."
[ Static crackling ]
Krrrrrrr!
That was static.
They wouldn't pay
for the second camera.
They wouldn't give us this.
And, look,
the drug might genuinely work
and be a major breakthrough,
which would be great,
but the president
shouldn't be talking it up
like he's filming a testimonial
for a prescription
drug commercial.
All that's missing are shots
of him walking on the beach
and playing guitar with a bunch
of other 70-somethings.
[ As Trump ]
Yeah, good jam session, fellas.
You know,
when you get to my age,
physical intimacy
can be a struggle.
That's why I take Regeneron.
Oh, where are they?
Where? You guys --
Melania, where's the Regeneron?
Mel?!
[ Laughter ]
Mel, I can't find
my intimacy pills.
Where you --
Where you threw them --
You flushed them down the
toilet by accident?
That keeps happening.
Well, Mel, I can't be
intimate with --
I'm not mad, Mel.
I'm not --
I love you, Mel.
So Trump's once again
bragging about miracle cures
he had the luxury of receiving
during his $100,000
taxpayer-funded hospital stay.
Meanwhile, his administration
is in court right now,
suing to rip healthcare
away for millions,
an outcome they could achieve
if they get their 6-3
Supreme Court supermajority.
Trump has left
the country in ruins
and, now, it's up to us
to put it back together.
More on that when we come back.
-[ Snarling ]
-Oh!
Raccoons are here.
♪♪
Welcome back.
So, before we go,
let's just quickly take stock
of where we're at right now.
The White House is emptier
than an abandoned
Hollywood Video
after a COVID outbreak infected
the president and his aides
and exposed potentially
thousands of others;
cases are, once again,
on the rise,
while just three states
report declines;
the president scream-tweeted
that he was unilaterally
ending stimulus talks,
then reversed himself;
Some of the country's
senior military leadership,
including members of the
Joint Chiefs are in quarantines;
raccoons have taken over
the White House;
and staffers have to wear masks,
gowns, and face shields
to enter the Oval Office,
like they're performing
an alien autopsy at Area 51.
Or, as the president put it...
-We have enthusiasm
like probably nobody's ever had.
Our people that love
the job we're doing.
We have more enthusiasm
than maybe anybody.
-[ As Trump ]
So much enthusiasm,
I guess you could say
it's contagious.
We're spreading it
across the country.
Everyone's got it and they're
giving it to their neighbors.
What all this shows is that
defeating Trump is the first
and most urgent step
to fixing our economy
and restoring our democracy,
but it can't be the only step.
We need systemic changes
to our political system
and a sustained moment
to push for them.
That starts with all of us
doing everything we can,
pitching in
and, most importantly --
most importantly --
voting.
We have the power to repudiate
Trump in November.
We can end the cruelty
and criminal negligence,
the cronyism, the incompetence,
and we're on the verge
of doing it.
We just have to see it through.
It's a nerve-racking place
to be, but it's also an...
-Exciting place to be.
-This has been
"A Closer Look Thursday."
Watch our show every night
at 12:35, right here on NBC.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
Vote.
We love you.
Good night.
♪♪
Oh, no!
Don't you --
I swear, of all the times!
We went, we bought
the puppet today, guys.
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
Wear a mask.
We love you.